sion social aussi et sans plus tarder
d'ailleurs je me tourne vers mes
collègues amis dont je m'ennuie beaucoup
beaucoup et bouchra wathiq et je viens
du salut ça va oui ça lui alexis
savalois pour être content de vous voir
même s'ils pensent chair et en os quand
même ça fait ça fait grand plaisir
alors depuis un mois on n'a pas chômé 1
depuis début de la crise
on est maintenant à quoi une quarantaine
d'articles publiés une vingtaine de
capsules vidéo tournée au compteur ça
fait pas mal et ça part en grande partie
d'une quantité hallucinante de courriels
construit jour après jour sa boucherie
jeff alors un petit mot d'ailleurs sur
cette abondance de courriels cette
demande qui est évidente de la
population qui cherchent à avoir de
l'aide pour qu'on puisse départager le
vrai du faux
alors en mode télétravail comment ça se
passe bouchons mais vraiment les gens
nous écrivent
c'est du jamais vu on reçoit des x 100
150 courriels par jour
donc si les gens se demandent pourquoi
on leur répond pas apparu c'est parce
qu'on reçoit énormément courriel et on
voit dans ces courriels que les gens
sont submergés d'informations que leurs
proches leurs envois et parfois ils nous
disent un membre de ma famille un ami à
ce recul a fait circuler ce jeu c'est
beaucoup en france et est ce que c'est
vrai on voit que les gens sont inquiets
parce que le corona virus ça peut être
une question de vie ou de mort et donc
les gens quand ils voient ces
informations là et ils sont très
inquiets que ce soit vrai ils reçoivent
parfois défaut conseils pour se protéger
ils savent pas s'ils doivent les suivre
donc vraiment on le sent beaucoup
d'inquiétude dans les questions que les
gens nous posent et on essaie d'y
répondre le plus rapidement possible
dans en faisant les articles
détroit jeff c'est ok le plus
d'expérience en la matière quand on
parle de lutte est la désinformation
avais tu déjà vu un tel volume de
fausses rumeurs de fausses croyances et
de désinformation non jamais jamais
jamais vu quelque chose mais s'approche
du va demander des informations qu'on
voit à propos de la copine 19 j'ai
jamais vu autant j'ai jamais reçu autant
de messages à propos d'un seul sujet ils
l'ont jugé que l'élection de 2007 aux
états unis qui nous a donné l'expression
fait news et même là on n'a jamais rien
de la sorte bush quand on peut pas
répondre à tous les courriels mais je
veux assurer tout le monde qui nous
écoutent
on lit tous c'est pas un système de
triage où on call it les informations
qui ont quitté les gens nous envoient
entre l école et plus prioritaires les
plus potentiellement dangereux ou les
choses qu'on reçoit le plus souvent mais
sachez qu'on a besoin de vous de vos
courriers donc même si on répond pas on
a besoin que vous nous dites circuit on
a besoin que vous soyez nos oreilles et
nos hull sur le terrain pour qu'on sache
si cette culture des réseaux sociaux
donc votre arrivée a été énormément
précieuse pour procurer au courant de ce
qu'ils demandent donc continuer
d'envoyer des courriels c'est ici
crucial je te seconde elle est sud est
sans contredit et je tiens à saluer au
passage des gens qui ont été appelés en
renfort pour nous aider étant donné le
volume de travail auquel on fait on fait
face mathieu gobeil nicolas de rosa on
les remercie pour pour le rapport à ce
travail essentiel et crucial dans le
contexte actuel alors allons-y
maintenant pour notre tour d'horizon de
la semaine et c'est parti
points chauds le garde de sécurité l'a
est venu me dire qu'elle n'avait pas de
prendre de photos ici
parking et vise pas l'institution à
l'hôpital je pose la main ce que ces
examens car beaucoup de corps la salle
des images qui ont été visionnées à près
de 15000 reprises jeff des images de
salles d'urgence vide et c'est assez
pour que certains y voient la preuve de
l'inexistence d'une crise sanitaire leur
est propre et domaine qu'on voit enfin
un peu partout au monde ça commence aux
états unis les gens ont commencé à 5
révisé journalistes citoyens allaient
dans leurs hôpitaux locaux et family
that d'urgence qui sont vides et le on
dit regardez on dit qu'une crise alors
paya personnes à l'urgence et on a vu ça
un peu partout dans le monde dans le vus
en france il ya eu des mots clics sur
les réseaux sociaux pour encourager les
gens à les filmer leurs hôpitaux
on a vu de la création de vos facebook
pour partager ses images le sait sauf
qu'en regard manceau ça peut avoir l'air
ça peut soulever des questions viennent
crime dans les hôpitaux pourquoi est ce
que les gens sont vides j'ai parlé à gm
à gauche et le docteur jivago chez qui
le président de l'association des
médecins spécialistes en urgence
esquissé dans le conseil ces prix bus ça
peut partir du plan du gouvernement du
québec pour parfaire ce à cette crise là
dont on ne pourrait demander aux
hôpitaux de maximiser les ressources
disponibles pour traiter les codes de
crevettes 19
et ça ça veut dire détourner certains
services qui était dédiée aux services
d'urgence dont par exemple on va peut
pas retenir les gens l'urgence pour
paris suivi on va pas des suivis plus
tôt au téléphone entre d'autres façons
de paris suivi comme ça ça fait partie
du plan donc c'est une bonne chose que
les gens soient des danses mama pas ce
que ça veut dire que les ressources sont
disponibles au un afflux de gens malades
avec la cabine
cela étant dit aussi ce qu'il obtient en
compte ce qui prive la population
québécoise suis très vite il conseille
de distanciation sociale donc on voit
beaucoup moins de visites à l'urgence
pour débiter petit cop de boutines donc
de la famille qui me disaient contre
beaucoup moins de co2 des visites à
l'urgence qui sont postés rieuse
donc les gens ont compris qu'il faut pas
aller à l'urgence un peu pour n'importe
quoi comme schématiser aussi coeur parce
que tous les conflits ça change le mode
de vie de tout le monde donc on voit
moins des accidents ou des crises
cardiaques des choses comme ça parce que
les gens restent à la maison donc tous
ces facteurs font en sorte que les
urgences ont beaucoup moins achalandé
que d'habitude on parlait avec comme
autour de 60%
pour ce qui des hôpitaux de montréal
alors que c'est que dans le fin à 110%
d'habitude ça veut pas dire qu'il ait
pas de crise à ne pas dire que la crise
est exagéré s'il est encore là mais
c'est plutôt un bon signe en fait ça
veut dire que nos hôpitaux ne sont pas
pour le moment sur manille par cette
crise dès que vous ne manquez pas
décédée comme quoi la crise est à
inventer quelque chose on peut on
pousser lui les efforts de notre système
de santé et de la population de rester à
la maison
exactement dans le but est de plats tire
la courbe et là je répèterai pas la
gestuelle de monsieur de dédit docteur
arruda
pour ce qui est de la courbe on va
maintenant parler de la chine chers amis
parce que ça aussi c'est un foyer
important de désinformation on a pu le
constater jour après jour notamment les
courriels que vous nous avez fait
parvenir alors dans le registre des
théories du complot la chine est un
incontournable pour les
conspirationnistes qui développe pas mal
d'obsession sujet là il semble que ce
virus était une décision du gouvernement
chinoise en réponse à la perte de la
guerre commerciale contre les états unis
l'objectif plongé le monde en récession
le scénario n'est t'il pas clair bah
voilà un bon exemple de cette époque de
théorie et conspirationnistes qui
circule beaucoup de courriels au sujet
de cette vidéo qu'on vient de voir cet
extrait convient de voir quittant mais
aussi avec des publications qui vont
dans le même sens et qui laisse croire
que la chaîne a créé ou sur vos
téléguidé la pandémie de toute pièce
pourquoi pour le bien de son économie
pour damer le pion à ses concurrents
pour mettre ses concurrents à genoux
finalement alors d'entrée de jeu pour
qu'une théorie comme cela tienne la
route mais il faudrait qu'ils existent
des données qui dit clairement que
l'économie chinoise tire profit de la
crise
ah ben c'est pas le cas selon des
spécialistes que j'ai que j'ai consultés
notamment notre collègue andré interne
aux journalistes spécialisés
amis ici à issy r10 et aussi florian men
risque est professeur d'économie à l'ucl
écoles d'essence la gestion à l'uqam
ce qu'on voit en ce moment c'est que dès
janvier février
l'économie de la chine le moteur
économique du monde entier a été amené à
0 au pratiquement et ensuite ce qu'on a
vu c'est une récupération très très très
infime des activités en chine il ya des
bosses ou six qui sont ceux qui sont
utilisés qui sont brandis en guise de
preuve entre guillemets que les choses
vont mieux en chine contrairement à
ailleurs dans le monde on dire qu'avec
les bourses chinoises ça va super bien
comparativement à ce qui se passe
ailleurs dans le monde et des petites
nuances qu'il faut apporter à ce
chapitre là comme nous le rappelait
andré hantz interne aux dés le mois de
décembre le voyez qui avait moins de
d'envolées spectaculaires dans les
secteurs dans les marchés boursiers
chinois on vieillit on voyait qu'ils
avaient moins de volatilité adore quand
la crise est survenue en plus de ça il y
avait la fermeture traditionnel des
marchés boursiers pour le nouvel an
lunaire
non pas dix jours mais très jour cette
année alors c'était complètement fermée
pendant cette fermeture des jeux le
gouvernement chinois étant donné la
crise avait annoncé des mesures
budgétaires et monétaires pour calmer
les choses et calmer les actionnaires ça
eu son effet sur les baux chinoise qui
explique entre autres le fait que ça va
un peu mieux de ce côté pour elle par
rapport au reste du monde
et quant à la reprise économique en
chine certains disent autre preuve que
c'est un coup monté ben vous voyez
l'économie chinoise rôle après à plein
régime
eh bien c'est faux si on regarde juste
le secteur manufacturier qui est un gros
morceau dans l'économie chinoise mais on
est à 40 ou 50 % de production tout et
c'est simple si la chine veut produire à
plein régime
faut qu'elle ait des débouchés des
débouchés il y en a pas il reste la
planète l'économie de la planète et pas
mal au ralenti en ce moment et puis sur
le fait que la chaîne aurait créé et le
virus en laboratoire est aussi un
antidote pour y remédier ben je vais pas
trop m'éterniser là dessus on sens a
déjà été prouvé à maintes reprises que
ça ne sort pas d'un laboratoire un des
études scientifiques qui prouvent très
clairement que c'est le fruit de
l'évolution naturelle et un vaccin va
falloir attendre quoi des deux ans à 18
mois avant que ça soit
une chose possible et envisageable ni la
chine encore en toile de fond de cet
extrait convient d'entendre bouchra en
fait ce qu'on voyait les faits ce qu'ils
nous disent c'est que c'est un extrait
du fbi haïk annonçait l'arrestation du
docteur charles diebel qu'on voit ici
sur ces images d'archivés qui selon
plusieurs conspirationnistes aurait
vendu le coronavirus à la chine oui donc
ils ces vidéos qui circulent nous on
voit donc un procureur américain qui dit
que cet homme a été arrêté
on enferme le nom de wuhan que la ville
où l'épidémie a commencé donc ça a l'air
suspect tout ça parce que il ya des gens
qui ont partagé cet extrait lacchini
réel qui n'est pas truquée et ils ont
mis comme titre l'arrestation du
concepteur de lakovic 19 ans plus de
seuil
une autre image qui circulait énormément
comme nous envoyer où on voit encore la
photo de ce chercheur américain chubb
libres et ont dit voici l'homme qui a
fabriqué et vendu le virus du corona à
la chine donc qu'est-ce qui est dans
premièrement si vrai que chose libre est
un chercheur de harvard
plus précisément directeur du
département de chimie et qu'il a été
arrêté le 28 janvier dernier par les
autorités américaines c'est vrai que son
arrestation avait un lien avec la chine
c'est vrai qu'il y avait un lien avec
buan mais ses locks arrête les faits et
tout le reste en lien avec le
coronavirus société de la théorie du
complot parce que les accusations
réelles auxquelles cet homme a fait face
elles n'ont aucun lien avec le virus
elles n'ont aucun lien avec la coved 19
en fait c'est que cet homme là ce
chercheur là il a accepté des fronts de
la chine dans le cadre d'un programme
qui vise au programme chinois qui vise à
recruter des experts des chercheurs de
tous les domaines pour qu'il travaille
au profit de la chine etc
selon le gouvernement américain ce
programme-là son intention réelle c'est
que la chine puisse faire en quelque
sorte de l'espionnage donc recruter des
chercheurs américains pour voler des
informations sensibles et les
transmettre à la chine
donc c'est un programme que le
gouvernement américain il circule alors
ce chercheur de harvard
non seulement ils étaient recrutés par
la chine dans le cadre de ce programme
là mais en plus il a caché le fait qu'il
était payé des dizaines de milliers de
dollars par mois par la chine
et ça c'est un crime aux états unis
parce que comme ce chercheur reçoit des
fonds des autorités américaines pour ses
recherches et harold il est tenu de
divulguer tout intérêt financier
étranger il a caché le fait qu'il était
payé par la chine
et voilà c'est la raison de son
arrestation et vous voyez que si vous
écoutez ce fameux vidéo qu'on entendait
il ya quelques instants ou deux
procureurs américains qui annonce son
arrestation il n'est jamais question de
coronavirus en fait ce chercheur le ce
n'est même pas un chercheur en virologie
c'est un chercheur en nanotechnologie
donc c'est un chercheur qui ne connaît
finalement pas grand chose au domaine
des virus il n'a jamais travaillé dans
ce domaine là alors voilà comment on a
pris une vraie histoire et qu'on l'a
convié à ajouter des défauts etc les
mains parce que ce chercheur russe a
donné qu'il était entre autres financé
par une université à one
mais là s'arrête le bien avec le corona
virus à sa star patten comme souvent vu
jeff bougera des gens dont l' expertise
et n'est pas nécessairement lié avec le
sujet dont il parle à kobe 19 en
l'occurrence dans le cas qui nous occupe
aura pour un peu perdre d'un mois
maintenant on l'a vu à bien des reprises
c'est important qu'on vérifie bien
qu'ils parlent et quel est son expertise
réelle n'est ce pas vous avez donc on a
vu énormément une vidéo des gens qui
triment dans leur salon dans la côte aux
impies qui affirment toutes sortes de
choses à propos du covan au virus
certains ont même l'air de savoir ce
dont ils parlent donc on certains
utilisent du langage extrêmement
technique donc maintenant quoi
réputation qu'ils sont médecins toujours
s'assurer le sait qui c'est qui cette
personne là
sur quelles sources d'information et se
base donc un bon truc là si vous voyez
une vidéo youtube allez voir la chaîne
youtube parce que ça nous apprend
beaucoup sur la personne une vidéo très
viral sur le corner virus qui a circulé
depuis depuis l'est de la semaine
dernière quand on a les bons la chaîne
youtube en question d'envoyer que cette
personne n'avait pu vidéo qui affirmait
que la lune n'existe pas alors que la
croissance des salaires des histoires
comme souvent ça donne une meilleure vie
des idées de la fiabilité de cette
personne
j'ai je me demandais bien oui je t'en
prie boucherie invasives pour pour
compléter ce que jeff dit donc que des
gens qui sont plus experts parlent on
constate aussi des mouvements des jeunes
augmente qui sont les gens qui créent
les fausses nouvelles et parfois c'est
des gens qui sont mal intentionnées qui
veulent créer la confusion qui vont
inventer des choses mais parfois c'est
des gens qui pensent avoir raison qu'ils
pensaient être de bonne foi parce qu'ils
ont lu des études qu'ils pensent être
réelle mais ils ont mal compris donc la
désinformation ça peut être accidentel
ça peut être des gens qui sont pas mal
intentionnés
donc il faut se méfier le même quand ça
ne vient pas de quelqu'un qui est
forcément qu'opérationnel exactement des
gens qui nous balance souvent plusieurs
plusieurs informations au visage lors de
ceux de ses longs monologues qui
malheureusement sont très populaires en
ce moment sur youtube
jeff je me demandais depuis le début
quand est-ce que yoann n va embarquer
dans tout cela
le groupe conspirationnistes qui ont
eux-mêmes qui a fait son entrée dans
avec la question de la coved 19
est ce qu'on entend à ce sujet est assez
particulier merci mais on a beaucoup de
messages de la part de lecteurs qui est
un peu confus par rapport à des messages
qu'ils ont vu circuler sur les réseaux
sociaux parfois le monde leur faire des
membres de leur famille leur a envoyé
des messages
ils ont vu circuit et pors doute à coeur
du message
un des messages directs il va avoir un
black out de l'internet en 3 euros dans
lequel dans notre enveloppe de
l'américain va déclarer la loi martiale
et par arrêté des centaines 2010-2015
posément pour des rituels cette année
qui pourra vous prélevez des substances
dans des cadavres d'enfants dans l'yonne
je suis circuit qui a affirmé que ben on
a découvert des tunnels
avec cent mille enfants un tunnel qui
reliait le port de new york à la
fondation clinton qui appartient au prix
de lancer président bill clinton et sa
femme hillary clinton
et on dit que le navire younès d'où le
navire hôpital qui étaient acheminés à
new york pour faire face à la crise deux
comédies nous ont dit que mais en face
on avait le sert à traiter ses enfants
ses enfants manoury maltraités confiance
supposément été kidnappé par la
fondation peloton on the run on dit
c'est pas qu'on y croyait fermement nous
demandait d'où ça vient ça parce que ça
sent de sa sortie de nulle part n'a
aucun sens commun des mortels on lit
ceci c'est quoi le rapport avec la gtx à
paris d'une conspiration que c'est elle
qui honore pour par une histoire longue
et un peu plus comme ces personnes une
petite fiole homme qui s'est donné le
nom qui lui depuis 2010 sur l'hippodrome
en ligne et affirmer tant haut placée
dans l'administration de dans notre pays
dit que dans le fond il tout tout le
chaos qu'on voit dans la politique
américaine c'est une mise en scène
cocasse finalement dans l'autre en
suisse
je vais prendre le contrôle du pays et
jeté ses opposants en prison donc toute
son histoire est liée à souvent des
histoires de trafic d'enfants on accuse
tous les opposants de dans l'autre choc
de 10,7 de part du trafic d'armes ou
rappelé la promesse musculation pizza
gars qui essaient de lui pendant
l'élection de 2007
on voudrait que le parti démocrate ça
découle en partie de sal et on a juste
continuer à parer votre lui c'est que
ces conspirations d'eau potable sur
l'attention ces considérations là ça
prouve nippon de l'internet et si on
connaît pas le contexte peut avoir
alarmant mais c'est clairement des
inventions
alors je le souligne est important de
rappeler chacun des sujets dont on vient
de parler depuis le début de cette
émission
jeff et bouchra aller retour sous forme
d'articles sur notre page web c'est
important de le souligner tout notre
contenu tout notre contenu sous forme
d'articles se trouve là je vous invite
vous y rendre le plus souvent possible
et en plus de ces vérifications de fait
qu'on effectue jour après jour semaine
après semaine des faits bouge pas ce
qu'on fait aussi se masser regarder ce
qui se dit ce qui s'écrit sur la
désinformation en général un peu partout
dans le monde
et commençons donc avec ce qui à capter
votre attention cette semaine si je
commençais par boucheron sur la hongrie
semble-t-il qu'ils arrêtent des citoyens
pourquoi pour des fausses nouvelles
oui mais justement avec si on en parlait
au mois d'octobre dernier à l'émission
on avait parlé de pourquoi est ce qu'on
ne rend pas les fausses nouvelles idées
gagnent c'est une question que les gens
se posent est ici xcs je t'explique est
ce normal c'est que les pays qui ont
décidé de rendre les forces nouvelles il
est égal c'est loin d'être des
démocraties ceux des pays qui veulent en
fait censurer les critiques et la
hongrie a franchi un pas important le 30
mars dernier le premier ministre a
décidé qu'il allait diriger le pays par
décret donc le parlement lieu donné les
pleins pouvoirs pour qu'ils puissent
diriger de façon indéterminée le pays
par décret sans la corde ça c'est donc
pour mieux gérer la crise donc c'est
l'argument avancé mais c'est ce château
rangement la hongrie fait en sorte que
dorénavant les citoyens pourront être
arrêtés parce qu'ils auraient partagé
des fausses nouvelles sur le coronavirus
et ceux dont s'inquiètent et défenseurs
des droits des prisonniers que les gens
qui vont se faire arrêter ça risque
d'être par exemple des journalistes qui
dévoilent que les le gouvernement n'aura
pas été transparent sur la crise ça
pourrait être des citoyens qui pose des
questions des critiques des gens qui
remettent en question le bilan alors ça
risque de faire très mal à la démocratie
à la liberté d'expression et la hongrie
n'est pas le seul pays qui fait ça on
voit qu aux philippines il ya d amende
très salée pour les gens qui
partageraient des fausses nouvelles sur
le coroner virus en egypte une
journaliste a été expulsé parce que dans
un article
elle remettait en question le bilan du
gouvernement donc on voit que la liberté
d'expression s'effrite sous prétexte de
bannir les forces nouvelles et ya pas
mal de pays dans le monde de pays assez
totalitaire qui vont dans cette
direction là bref il faut se méfier
oui donc je voudrais rappeler aussi que
au tout début de la crise on avait vu un
cas vraiment si la grand halle de ça on
en avait parlé même à l'émission c'est
un ophtalmologiste chinois qui avait été
le premier à sonner la fin décembre il
avait dit il ya un virus qui s'en vient
et qu'est ce que le gouvernement chinois
afin ce moment là était il l'a accusé
d'avoir propagé des rumeurs fausses mais
on sait maintenant que ce médecin avait
raison et malheureusement il est décédé
lui même 18 de la comédie net oui le
docteur lee qui fait figure de héros de
martyr aux yeux de bien des chinois qui
malgré tout ne crois pas là ce que leur
sert le régime c'est-à-dire le
gouvernement central à pékin et jeff
donc au delà de ces mesures liberticides
comprend peu partout dans le monde comme
en hongrie
parlons maintenant des néonazis et de ce
qu'on peut dire à leur sujet en lien
avec la comédie 19
mais oui on parlait dans un épisode
plutôt cette raison de l'accélération
est une
un courant particulière particulièrement
extrême des du néonazisme qui prend
l'accélération de l'effritement sociale
donc provoquer provoqué la chute de la
civilisation occidentale à partir de
moyens que certains des moyens
terroristes ou des actions de genre et
baignoire à porte du style intelligence
bros qui était une entreprise de
renseignement privé qui surveille tout
l'extrémisme et sur les réseaux sociaux
donc pas seulement l'état islamique mais
les néo nazis aussi ce qu'ils ont trouvé
ce que dans vie privée pour il y perd
tous les jeunes l'ignominie plus
particulièrement extrémistes au prom
d'utiliser la désinformation à des fins
d'accélération est donc pour provoquer
la chute du gouvernement américain et
certains exemples qu'il donne c'est par
exemple ce tribut des fausses affiches
dans des communautés juives ou
musulmanes disant aux gens de réussite
si vous éprouvez des symptômes de pub 19
allée ou réfugiées à la mosquée ou à la
synagogue dans le but de propager
les taux d'infection ces communautés là
on est aussi du sahara par le maire de
laval et de propager dans les réseaux
sociaux des forces nouvelles des fausses
rumeurs pour augmenter la confusion chez
la population est un des exemples qu'on
ait évoqué c'était daly daly daly dans
les villes section commentaires de
journaux et de combats de logements
comme pour l'art me serait sur le point
d'occuper le territoire dont lé
dirigeant tendu mon cousin et dans
l'armee qui me dit que l'armée va
débarquer il aucune autre ville
oui je dis pas qu'ils ont eue guimond a
vu des rumeurs comme ça se fait au
québec il ya quelques semaines y avait
des vidéos sur unix vous est que la
remise en venait à montréal l'année des
véhicules militaires à montréal donc à
partir de la tension quand on partage du
meurtre comme ça parce qu'on sait pas
peut-être est-ce que ça peut pas partie
d'une campagne de propagande des
courants les plus extrémistes du web
donc vraiment c'est ça avant de partager
si vous avez des doutes pensez-y un peu
puis écrivez-nous pourquoi pas
décrypteurs pour qu'on y rejette un
petit coup d'oeil c'est important de le
rappeler également mois ce qui a attiré
mon attention basses et entre autres
watson qui a sévi contre les chaînes de
messages watts heure pour le comprendre
pour ceux qui connaissent moins ça c'est
un service de messagerie crypté privée
qui appartient au groupe facebook c'est
pas mal de monde c'est entre un milliard
et demi et 2 milliards d'utilisateurs
actifs à travers le monde
est ce qui a été pris comme décision du
côté de what's up pour lutter contre la
désinformation c'est limité les
possibilités d'un partagé un même
message plus de cinq fois ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est quoi soop sur what's up
les messages se propage assez rapidement
parce qu'il suffit de les transmettre
on s'est passé plutôt de les transmettre
d'un seul coup à l'ensemble de son
carnet d adresse alors on comprend que
c'est assez exponentielle très
rapidement alors on a voulu agir vite
parce que c'est ce à travers ces canaux
là que la désinformation sur la kobe 19
s'est mis à circuler à circuler un
circuit dans un rythme assez effréné et
sadek tes fesses
pas plus tard que l'été dernier par
what's up la même mesure
en 1/2 quand une fausse rumeur avait
occasionné bien tristement la mort de 25
personnes alors on voit qu'un ex
prennent ça au sérieux parmi les grandes
plateformes peut-être pas assez au goût
de certains
mais il ya des mesures qui elles sont
mises de l'avant on a vu que youtube
twitter et facebook ont carrément retiré
des taux d des messages provenant du
président brésilien gvt au sonar qui est
lui-même un sur vingt personnes qui
doutent fortement de la sévérité et de
la gravité de la situation actuelle
alors on a retiré ses messages à pour
protéger la sécurité du public et on a
vu cette semaine aussi au double
s'attaquer aux vidéos conspirationnistes
qui lie la 5g et le coronavirus et même
au canada il faut le rappeler il ya de
l'argent des sommes additionnelles qui
ont été injectés cette semaine par le
gouvernement fédéral pour lutter contre
la désinformation
bref on n'est pas les seuls au
décrypteurs à essayer de faire changer
les choses et renverser la vapeur face à
ces informations qui nuisent à l'intérêt
public et jeff et bouge pas c'est un
plaisir de voir et de vous entendre
je suis un plaisir partagé bah ouais je
sais pas quand est ce qu'on va se revoir
mais j'ai bien géré bien de vous serrer
la pince ou à tout le moins un petit
coup de caunes montserrat virtuellement
ici c'est important pour respecter la
distanciation sociale alors à vous qui
nous écoutent et qui vous nous regardez
continue à nous suivre à nous écrire par
courriel n'hésitez pas faire comme les
26000 personnes qui ont rejoint jusqu'à
maintenant notre groupe facebook adhéré
aussi à notre infolettre est qu'on
publie semaine après semaine
alors au nom de toute l'équipe à la fois
ce que vous voyez en ce moment sur votre
écran et ceux qui travaillent aussi avec
nous à nos côtés je vous dis ça lui
portez vous bien
prenez soin de vous roy
[Musique]